what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
news about two very very anticipated
exciting projects coming up in Marvel's
Cinematic Universe it looks like we
could have figured out two of the titles
for phase six and their exact release
dates and we're talking right now about
Deadpool 3 and Xiang Chi and the legend
of the tin rings too although it
probably won't be titled legend of the
tin Rings it'll probably be something
else but like I said we could have
official release dates for these two
movies today and even though Marvel
Studios is trying to be pretty secretive
with phase six that doesn't mean that we
can't actually figure some stuff out
because it looks like we did so let's go
ahead and dive into today's news also if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news so let's start
with Deadpool 3 because I know myself
personally was really expecting an
announcement for Deadpool 3 for Marvel's
Phase 6 at Disney's d23 Expo but of
course we did not get that clearly
Marvel is trying to save some surprises
to reveal next year possibly at sdcc
2023 which I totally understand but it
seems like we have figured out the
official release date for Deadpool 3.
you see as most people have probably
noticed or maybe know already Marvel
Studios plans out the release dates for
all of their projects way in advance
sometimes they don't put the titles with
those projects so the public doesn't
know and they try to keep us in the dark
and keep us surprised but most of the
time we do get those release dates and
now that Marvel has given us all of the
titles for Phase 5 officially attached
to those release dates and given us some
of phase six and release dates for phase
six as well we can pretty much figure it
out and it looks like before Deadpool
actually had a release date of February
16th of 2024 however it now appears like
that release date has moved but only a
little bit so don't worry too much the
Hollywood reporter's Boris kit shared
that an Untitled Marvel movie that was
previously slated on February 16 2024
has now moved to September 6th of 2024.
now before this change happened this
original spot February 16th of 2024 was
already believed to be Deadpool and
here's why Marvel Studios before this
had five release dates scheduled with no
movies attached to them they had
November 3rd 2023 February 16th May 3rd
July 26th and November 8th of 2024. then
at San Diego Comic-Con these dates were
actually filled with blade Captain
America new world order the Thunderbolts
and Fantastic Four but now that February
16th date has been moved to September
6th and it looks like Deadpool 3 might
now start off phase six of the MCU not
the Fantastic Four right now Deadpool is
the next upcoming project that we know
is confirmed and they have recently
signed a director and art director and
even writers and of course Ryan Reynolds
has been working on the script for for
years now so Deadpool 3 is already in
production it's about to start filming
pretty soon the time slot before was
already rumored to be Deadpool 3 and now
it's pretty much the only movie that we
know to be in production that's left
without an official release date so this
does most likely belong to this release
slot which means that Deadpool 3 is
going to be kicking off phase six now as
far as what this movie could actually be
about we're not really sure at this
point in time there are rumors that
Deadpool is not only going to be coming
by himself but he'll be bringing cable
Domino and possibly even some of the fox
X-Men who could participate in secret
Wars which then would eventually
introduce the true X-Men of our Marvel
Cinematic Universe for phase seven now I
personally would really really love to
see a Deadpool kills the fox Universe
storyline playing off the story Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe the book by
Cullen Bunn I think this would be the
perfect opportunity to do this and I
have heard rumors that they are
considering this storyline line for
Deadpool 3 but that was a while ago so
they could have very well changed their
mind I haven't heard anything about that
in a while but for right now although it
is not officially confirmed we are
expecting that September 6th of 2024
release date to B4 Deadpool 3. and now
moving on to Shang Chi 2. recently Seema
Liu who of course plays shangchi has
heavily implied that he is going to be
popping up in the MCU and other projects
before we get Shang Chi too we don't
know the particular projects where he's
going to show up yet some have assumed
She-Hulk since they're doing a ton of
cameos and since he is associated with
Wang now and of course in the movie we
actually did see Wong fight Abomination
which was addressed in She-Hulk but that
is not confirmed so don't expect that
but that could be a nice little surprise
now if you're not aware Xiang Chi 2 was
already confirmed by Marvel Studios they
are making a sequel to the film it does
look like shangchi is going to be a
primary Avenger moving forward even
though right now we don't really have an
event Avengers team and Kevin feige did
confirm this that there really isn't one
in the MCU right now there are no
Avengers not yet at least because
obviously we have Avengers the King
Dynasty coming up followed up by
Avengers secret War so the Avengers are
going to have to assemble pretty soon
and it might start actually it probably
will start with Wong Wong seems to be at
the middle of everything happening in
the MCU right now and right now he is
the sorcerer Supreme and although Doctor
Strange wasn't too involved with the
Avengers before Avengers Infinity War I
think it's a little bit different for
Wong and I think it's going to be Wong
and Falcon slash the new Captain America
who kind of bring the Avengers team
together and I think we'll see this in
shangchi and the legend of the ten Rings
because the release date is before the
King Dynasty and Secret Wars now right
now rumor has it that Marvel Studios is
eyeing a February 14 2025 release date
for Shang Chi 2. this was reported on by
the direct and Charles Murphy of
Murphy's mom diverse seem to back this
up as well online a shangshi and the
legend of the tin Rings director Dustin
Daniel [ __ ] has recently been
confirmed to be directing Avengers the
King Dynasty so this kind of connects
here if you connect the dots this makes
sense the King Dynasty is an Avengers
film and if the Avengers are going to
start forming and chiangchi is going to
be a big Avenger and his movie is coming
right before the King Dynasty it would
make sense for Dustin Daniel [ __ ] to
return to direct shanxi too because it
leads right into his next movie the King
Dynasty like leading right into it
shangshi would be in February and then
the King Dynasty would be May 2nd of
2025. now there has actually been a
little bit of a debate recently on
whether or not Dustin Daniel [ __ ]
would return to Direct shangchi One
because he is also producing the Wonder
Man series that Marvel Studios is about
to release as well so many fans think
that because he is going to be directing
Avengers the King Dynasty and going to
be producing wonder man that he won't
actually have have time to direct Shang
Chi too however Charles Murphy of
Murphy's Multiverse stated he's
absolutely directing shangchi too I
don't know why people keep thinking that
producing Wonder Man would take
precedence over Shang Chi 2 producing
doesn't mean he's necessarily doing much
of anything and that can be true for
producing sometimes not a ton of time is
required when you're producing a film
especially if there are many producers
attached to it and over a year ago when
shangshi came out I actually interviewed
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] and he was excited
to return to do a sequel so I would be
shocked if he didn't return to direct
Shang Chi too and I think he did such an
amazing job on the very first shangchi
and the legend of the ten Rings film
that Marvel Studios definitely wants him
to return as well but as of right now it
looks like we tentatively have release
dates for Deadpool 3 and Chung Chi 2.
and these are two movies that I am just
super super excited for and I hope you
all are too but let me know all of your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on on the
latest MCU news for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof